joining us here on the rich eisen show
uh is the man of the hour as i referred
to him when he
kindly answered his phone absolutely
knowing probably why i was calling
earlier here on tuesday he's ian
rappaport uh my colleague from the nfl
media group how are you ian
i thought you were just calling to be
sure i was okay after the uh
thrashing from jerry jones well you got
smoked
you said you were smoking ribs today i
guess you got smoked
you know i am smoking ribs as a matter
of fact just put three racks in the
parallel smoker
uh with a little apple uh little apple
sort of flavored wood
at the bottom um so a lot of good things
going on there
um as far as jerry jones you know it's
it's interesting because
i think you know five or six or seven
years ago maybe i would have been upset
by this it was a very mean thing to say
um but i believe my information i've
talked to many people involved
it's been two days and the cowboys have
not
even made an offer to earl thomas which
you would think if he was someone
a free agent they wanted that they would
make an offer
i do not expect them to make an offer so
that's kind of where we stand i get it
um jerry jones is awesome and can say
whatever
but i trust my information as well well
ian it's interesting you you get the
same
uh emails as i do from the stellar nfl
media group uh newsdesk which is
on top of everything and i got an email
over the weekend
pointing out that gerald mccoy um in the
way that
um his season unfortunately ended saves
the cowboys about three and change on
the cap
redoing tyron smith's contract saved
them
seven million on the cap you added it
all up together and that sounds like a
nice 10 million dollar
spot for someone of earl thomas's
caliber
in a place where earl has made it very
well known he wants him
and um you put two and two together you
come up four why
why would the cowboys not be interested
in earl thomas
uh so yes you are right about that um
the the cowboys conversion of tyron
smith's base salary to a signing bonus
actually was
that had been in the works for several
weeks it was really just a matter of
time that actually came before the
gerald mccoy injury i mean it was
processed after yes but the plans to do
it came before
um i don't think it's about money
i get the sense it's more are we sure
that we want to bring
someone like he's a great player he is a
great player
but are we sure that we want to bring
everything
that he has done into the locker room
and that's
you know i mean one hand he's a pro
bowler on the other hand
you've had two very good very respected
consistently winning organizations
decide that they would prefer to have
him not play safety for them
um that is concerning and i think for
you know mike mccarthy when he's got
you know he's got hillary clinton dicks
he's nadal thomas he's got darian
thompson actually he's played really
well in camp but also material thomas
much cheaper don't present the issues
that thomas presents
i think that's probably more what's
going on here than anything
well well then let's uh let's get a
little bit more under the hood here
about earl thomas what
what in the world is going on i mean uh
you know mike silver whose
information is as uh excellent as
anybody else's in the business and i
don't
discount it at all you know reporting
that he
did he really did earl thomas really
tell and by the way when i say that
again
as i said on yesterday's show i'm not
calling mike silver's
um uh information into question but earl
thomas's
uh thought process did he really tell
the ravens or harbaugh or his coach like
you know i need more time to get my car
washed in between practice
and a meeting did that literally come
out of earl thomas's mouth
yeah i would never defend anyone doing
anything like that but i would say it is
difficult to get your car wash when
you're working all the time
i mean they have companies that actually
come to your house and do it
that's a little more expensive but that
can be really beneficial
i would say next time that's what i
would recommend if that was like the
option of meetings or car wash
um now to be fair i only drive like 10
miles a week at most so i'm not a big
car wash guy um but anyway i don't doubt
silver's information i did not know that
specifically but i don't doubt his
information
um it's not it's not great
um there's definitely some some stuff
there and i think for teams
you know who have to investigate
spending look
it's a pandemic and no one wants to
spend any money right like the cardinals
just invested a whole bunch of money in
buda baker he is their own guy his
character is impeccable
he's a great player and he's young those
are the kind of players you spend money
on
earl thomas is also a great player but
is older
it's expensive and has had some issues
in a pandemic
you see teams hold on to their wallet
much tighter than
you otherwise might i i guess
then you just see buddha baker hit the
jackpot but again
um you know at the safety position which
by the way according to brockman i did
not see this that caused jamal adams to
trend right chris
yeah buddha baker not trending jamal
adams adam's trending
i mean for real is that true yeah yeah
because
i put those those uh facts together
because jamal i mean
you know the seahawks are gonna have to
pay jamal adams based on what they gave
up for him
so that that's you know but um you know
i want to put a pin in that
for a second to return to this whole
scenario so
you know that this is why you infuse
your language
in your end of the business with
expected to there are no plans
you know you don't say anything you know
with uh with certainty
and yet you did you did you did put the
crying emoji
at the end of like you poured one out
for the earl thomas cowboy relationship
oh i know that but do you think that's
what set off jerry i mean what do you
think set him off
on this whole subject ian um
you know i i don't know i mean i know he
was i know he was on the radio
planning to talk about earl thomas sure
so
i mean and i knew he knew he was going
to be asked about earl
thomas did i did i ruin it by going on
early
maybe i think that's possible i don't
know that but i'm just
i'm just trying to think what would get
him so upset i mean i also was surprised
when he came after me for my dak
prescott report which was clearly true
so i i mean remind everyone what that
was for remind everyone what that was
about
ian so in november on game day morning i
reported that
jack prescott was going to get franchise
tagged at the end of the year which
honestly to me seemed obvious i knew
what was going on the talks were nowhere
they weren't going to pick up
he was getting tagged regardless and
jerry said he has no idea what he's
talking about and it was weird to me
because i was like
okay well first of all like i do second
of all everyone knows he's getting
tagged so
okay and i mean for a few of the cowboys
it's been two and a half days
you haven't made an offer to you know
the top free agent out there
which means he could sign with anyone at
any point before you even make an offer
that is a pretty solid indication that
he's not at the forefront of your
thinking
so i i don't i don't know what set him
off um
he should just call me and we should
talk about it but i i really don't know
your number is uh you can access it but
i guess you know
i if i had a guess and you know we're
we're walking on that tightrope of
of supposing what uh jerry jones is
thinking here on
four different uh live distributions
actually in to
you know to put a fine point on it that
maybe
i mean rich i i think i think we should
mention before you go on
um this is my first time on the peacock
okay yep
have you done anything to commemorate
this momentous day well i have this uh
large stack of post-it notes with a
peacock logo
on all four sides that i can send to you
so you can write post-it notes and
remind yourself not to piss jerry jones
off and post it on the fridge
you know to be that simple if you send
that i will put that on the instagram
i'm done absolutely done uh i hope uh
the problem is though is i don't want to
create a problem with my staff is del
tufa gets really pissed that he's not
getting these things um and i don't
this may this may create a rift and i
don't know what he's talking about thank
you very much appreciate that mike there
you go
yeah you just played them don't you just
sabotage it
but uh i forgot what i even asked you
after one of this podcast oh yeah
so i if i had to if i had to guess again
he's the owner
and he's the guy who makes the final
decisions so you know
um it's not as if uh any coach in the
history of the dallas cowboys has ever
received a player that he wasn't totally
sold on because jerry wanted it
and thinks it's best for the team and
also in the case of dak you know for you
to say that in november
he might be sitting there thinking how
does he know i'm not just going to cough
up the money
sometime in january he doesn't know my
negotiating strategy
if i had to guess that's probably what
he's thinking he could change the tenor
of any conversation about any player
about the dallas cowboys
as he wishes at any time he wishes is
essentially what his point might be
and he's right he's the owner i mean i
remember you know there was
i was reporting on some player was
choosing between two teams and i knew
that he was going to go the other way
so i reported that he was expected to
sign with this one team and i get a call
from the gm the other team
and he says why would you report that
and i said well he's you know
he's going to choose the other team and
then the response was well you don't
know what we're going to offer i said
i know what you've offered and he's
turned that down he's going the other
way and then
the follow-up was well yeah but we could
just increase the offer and i'm like
well yes technically anyone can do
anything
technically jerry could just write a
huge check pay earl thomas
40 million dollars over one year and get
it done um
but that's not expected to happen here
we are
it's not expected to happen it's as
opposed to
we're we're no longer crying emoji
pouring one out
um okay so last one for you what else is
the biggest story that's going on the
false positives that happened
earlier this week and what the nfl is
planning to do to make sure if something
that rare event as they have referred to
it
uh now through a statement uh happens
again
are they going to start testing players
final testing for a game on a friday and
then quarantine
everybody before kickoff is that
essentially what the plan's going to be
ian for the season i i don't know if
they're going to do it on
i don't know if they're going to do it
on friday
i know that's been discussed what i
think the biggest takeaway from
all of this is something the nfl is
going to work with these these labs and
with
bioreference their testing pointer on is
making sure that let's say
let's say tom brady is walking into the
facility on sunday morning
you know he gets there at you know 9 30
or something
we show him rolling through the stadium
with his cool
like stupid vest or whatever and then he
gets a
health check and his temperature's over
and then they test him
and he's positive okay well there's
going to be a test there's a saliva test
now that can have results in a matter of
hours
there's also some other point of care
test that can have results faster than
that
the nfl is going to work toward
clarifying and confirming those results
as fast as they possibly can so if this
happens on a saturday night at a team
hotel
if this happens sunday morning walking
into the stadium you can make sure that
if someone's going to be held out
he's really going to be positive i think
that's the main thing that is going to
be discussed here
how quickly can you find out test
results to confirm that a guy you think
is covered positive
actually is right and we had george
kittle on yesterday
and um and belichick as well he was the
first guest here
on our peacock um quadcast
and you know kittle said he
he's confident that if everybody follows
the rules
of engagement outside of the facility
that there can be a full nfl season
without interruption
and belichick basically also said you
know look they they talk about all the
time about personal responsibility and
i'm sure he's delivered
a very stark message to the team about
uh having your
entire life be about your football life
and as long as everybody can figure that
out in the nfl for
four and a half or if they're so
fortunate six months out of their lives
to have their entire life be about their
football life we can have a football
season
uh but i am holding my breath to be
honest with you that ever since full
pads go
went went on uh about eight days ago
this is when you can start seeing the
manifestation of some sort
of uh somebody showing signs of covet if
they picked it up this is i'm i'm kind
of getting
you know um if we can get through this
week you know with the same
results that we heard our debts dr alan
sills said yesterday the chief medical
officer between the 12th and the 20th no
covet positive tests
at all um is this the general sensor
you're hearing from from everybody in
the nfl about the season
yeah i mean it's all good right so the
fact that there's been no player test
positive over the last seven days is
amazing
and it also makes sense because like
that was part of the thought process
here and i know
you know i i don't mean to say that you
know players who opted out didn't have a
reason to everyone has their own
personal reasons to and i really
you know i really don't know the
personal reasons for a lot of players
but as i heard the opt-outs
those that were not specifically health
related the thing i kept thinking was
i imagine these facilities are going to
be some of the safest places on earth
like you're tested all the time you have
a million medical experts making sure
that everything is clean everyone's
social distance by
by rule i mean it is it is insanely safe
so i think that is one thing that's
going to keep the nfl on the field but
rich i would say my main thing is yes
like
we're going to start i think it's all
going to be good the issue to me
is let's say you have a 2-16
and you know the coach is on his way out
and things are going bad
do guys just start going out and say
screw it
and then if that team you know if
someone has a positive test because they
kind of somehow
you know don't show up in a pregame
screening
does that person then play an undefeated
team and then you have a real problem
so that would be my only thing where i'm
like everyone needs to keep on this
because
if you have a team that stop starts
saying who cares
you know and slacks off that could
affect everyone the
you know the old backing up the u-haul
as dion would always call it
players just backing up the u-haul
getting ready to just move out
you know for the season because they
know their season's over
if if uh players get lacks on that front
yeah i
that would be um disheartening to say
the least
you know um so let's end let's land on a
on an upbeat note how else uh can you
get into trouble
before i let you go uh ian you want to
talk about dez you want to talk about
dez's possibility coming back and
what i guess what what's uh what let's
do that what's the
what's the uh what's the okay what's the
what's the scoop here
what happened with baltimore and why do
you walk out without a contract
um i would say um
i'm gonna keep keep my eyes peeled on
that one i heard the workout was pretty
good
um he obviously wasn't signed so it
could have been that that good or maybe
it's an issue of money
but i was told it's something they're
gonna keep in touch on now one issue is
when he leaves as you know
he's out of the you know sort of pseudo
bubble right
so if he comes back he has to go through
testing again and it's another five days
or so
until he can actually be in the building
in practice so like you're starting to
come
to a little time now before the season
if players are going to be on the team
before the season like they're going to
need to sign soon like you had
just for instance like stefan gilmore
with the patriots left camp
for a personal matter came back needed
to spend four days going through testing
just to get on the field again
missed one day ended up missing five
days so you know dez's window is kind of
running out but
um i would say his workout was pr
was pretty good um and i'd be curious if
other teams that have other receiver
workouts
are going to take a look at them i just
haven't heard that they are yet
all right ian this is uh an excellent
chat i appreciate it you sound great um
it's not an easy day when uh when you
have uh
a hall of fame owner basically say what
what did bait what did he
say mike delta he doesn't know what he's
talking about that's exactly that
um and hey that should be your ringtone
make it your ringtone or you know own it
you know when jerry calls me i'll set it
i'll set it to ring
you get your text down exactly um and as
you know
um uh 14 years ago um
al davis called out your predecessor and
your role at the nfl network adam
schefter is a false rumor monger
saying basically the same thing that uh
jerry jones said
saying that uh uh adam couldn't have
gotten his information from a reliable
source because there's only one reliable
source and he doesn't trust adam that
does
ring true a little bit it does sound a
little bit similar to what we heard
he was right wasn't he he certainly was
art shell was indeed no no longer the
coach of the raiders after 2006 that is
correct
he was right that's so that's that's a
phone drop that's a phone drive
thanks a call ian you take care of
yourself brother all right that's
interrupt port my colleague from the nfl
media group
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here